so you just came from Paris Fashion Week  you just landed in the lanyard's still  on from it and there's a photograph on  it what is that it's a photograph of a  baby's ultrasound  why is that and that you designed that  yes why what does that mean uh it just  represents life and pro-life  boy so you wear it on a badge what what  kind of response do you get and good  amen I agree I don't care about people's  responses I care about the fact that  there's more  black babies being aborted and born in  New York City at this point that 50 of  Black Death  in America is abortion so I really don't  care about people's responses I perform  for audience of one and that's God  subscribe to the Fox News YouTube  channel to catch our nightly opens  stories that are changing the world and  changing your life from Tucker Carlson  tonight